[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN TRUEMAN: Musical
instruments are
amazingly interdisciplinary.
I mean, basically,
to understand what's
going on with a musical
instrument involves touching
on so many different
disciplines,
whether it's physics and
acoustics or perception
and cognition.
Whether it's interfacing -- like
how we interface with machines
or devices through something
like the keyboard or the violin
bow.
MAYA KEREN: I'm currently
undecided about my major,
but I'm definitely
interested in music.
And I'm also thinking
about computer science.
This class is basically the
intersection of those two
interests, in addition
to some other topics
like physics and math.
AATISH BHATIA: I co-teach
this course with Dan Trueman.
And I think having this
interdisciplinary approach,
we have many
different perspectives
on the same question,
and they all kind of
build upon each other.
And so to me, that's
one of the things that's
really exciting about
collaborative teaching,
is that it allows us to build
on each other's perspectives
and really build, I think,
a more well-rounded course.
[CHATTER]
ELI BERMAN: So today, we're
building some overtone flutes
out of some PVC pipes.
So using the natural resonance
of these materials to
activate different frequencies.
We figure out what
fundamental pitch
we want to be the base level
pitch of the instrument,
and then we calculate how
long the PVC pipe should be.
SUBJECT: It's
between 28 and 28.01.
MAYA KEREN: Perfect
Let's do that.
Basically, my lens
in how I see music
is very influenced by my
path as a jazz pianist.
And I think this class
is going to open up
this whole new realm
of possibilities for me
in terms of where I
can take the music.
[FLUTE PLAYING]
ELI BERMAN: I had never
gone through the process
of making any instrument.
So it's really fascinating
to be able to see the care
that's needed to create an
instrument that works at all,
or that sounds at all.
And then to see what other
details can be made to make it
work in the way
that you want to.
DAN TRUEMAN: Eli
and I were listening
to the same pair
of notes, and they
were hearing different
difference tones in their head
then I was hearing.
So we were just hearing
different things
based on our experience, based
on, probably, our physiology.
It's a really important lesson
to learn for young musicians --
that there's no absolute
sound that we're all hearing.
Like, it's a very
personal thing.
And that's an important
thing to know and realize
when you're sharing
music with other people,
and you're trying to be
empathetic and understand what
other people are experiencing.
AATISH BHATIA: Music is one
example of a place where
you can experience it
and you can enjoy it
without necessarily having
an understanding of what
makes things sound good.
But once you're at that place,
gaining that understanding --
so like, trying to use math
and science and physics
to understand what is actually
happening when I hear a violin
note, or what is actually
happening when I hear a chord
that I really like --
that adds to our
understanding of it.
So I think finding spaces
where science, engineering,
math, intersect with
things like music
that people are often
already passionate about
is the really
interesting way for me
to try to bridge these things
together and try to make
science more accessible.
[FLUTE PLAYING]
MAYA KEREN: I think that any
way that you kind of see music
from a different
lens, whether it's
from a historical lens or
a very theoretical lens --
and in this sense, it's kind of
like a physical and scientific
lens, if you're going
to make new discoveries.
And I think in this case
a lot of the discoveries
are based on digging up
what is the actual physical
and scientific foundations of
how music is made in the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]